Ngay mùm bẩy tháng 5 vừa qua, con tí của phần sớt nhé khẩu bên trẻ bây truy mếc đã khánh thành đoàn nhà văn phòng mới tại Sau Mi Ba Kau Thắng, Quận Ba, thành phố Xí Minh.
Điểm nhấn đặc biệt của tuàn nhà chính là Trung Tâm Ginh kiu và Phát Chỉnh, Aynh đi, hiện đại đôi trong hị cất bị tiền tiến.
Chúng tâm Aynh đi của bây truy mếc là không giang Ginh kiu, Phát Chỉnh sẽ phát công nghệ cao trong sản xuất và Chỉnh Các sản phẩm tư dừa.
Íng dộ kho học công nghệ và tôi yêu gí thức, tăng cường đổi mối sáng tạo trong nghiên cứu nân cao chủi giả chị nông sản, tôi yêu quy trình sản xuất, tư đó, kên tạo chủi giả chị giữa bên bứng, đáp ứng tư trình nghiêm hạt về ăn toàn thực phẩm và chứ xuất mùn gốc.
Phát biểu tại sự kiện mà đặc biệt, bà đặc biệt lúc mi, chú tịch hộ đồng quan chị về thuy mếc khẳng định, biệt hình thành tòa nhà phần phòng xanh hiện đại trình lý câu.
Bối nghiệm đến là Trung tâm ai đi thiết tiến là bước kia chiến lực, hiện thức khoá mục biểu đưa Việt Nam trở thành Trung tâm đổi mối ngành dừa toàn cầu.
Bước là Trung tâm ai đi tại thành phố Xí Minh tạo điều kiện thở lợi cho bế thuê mếc tiếp cận mạng lối chi thức, đổi mối sáng tạo đi hợp tác cùng các trường đại học và việc nghiên cứu hàng đầu trong nước và khu vực.
Công vời sự hợp tác tế với các dân nghiệp tại thủ phủ dừa của thế giới như Indonesia, bết ruy mếc cảm chủ đậu của mình với liệu, tăng cơm năng lực cảnh tranh vướng để mục tiêu sản lực 3 chấm chữ đi trên kêu gạm.
Theo Rang View Reset, khi chương sần phòng tự dừa có thể đặt hơn 2.5 tí UHD và năng hành hủ chăm 2.5 và tức tục tăng mạnh nhiều suy hỗng thức phòng hiểu cơm, mỹ phòng, dừa phòng tự thiên nhìn.
Dừa cũng là loài kê có khả năng hấp dụ, 10 2 cao mối hế ta lên đến 18 năm tình năm góc phần quan trọng vào mục tiêu không chất thải, Zero West của Việt Nam năng hành hình khu chăm năm hơi.
Chúng tâm ai đi không chỉ là nơi thương viện công nghệ thiên tiến mà còn là hạt nhân của chỉ lực ra giảm ła sản phẩm. Đáp ứng thiệu thì chương tần câu tục phòng đổ uống đến lý phẩm và dục phẩm vừa.
Mình cảm hoạt động sản xuất, mẹ thuê mê còn tin phòng trong việc kết nối chi tức quốc tục thông qua hội thả quốc tế thường viên.
Dên liên là hội thả quốc tế của con ấy, của em năm 2019 với sự tham sự của các chuyên gia, giến giả hành động ngành giờ tự Indonesia, Philippines, Malaysia.
Mới những lỗ lực mang tính chính lực này, mẹ thuê mê khẳng định và cho tin phong và lăng phỏa sử mệnh phát triển ngành giờ Việt Nam bên bước.
Đưa những sản phẩm vào ý tính ngành giờ Việt quân gia trên bản đồ lông nghiệp thế giới.